well clearly this story is moving on a
pace and it now looks as though Asha
King will at some point in the next few
weeks be coming here to the proton
Center in Prague for treatment we get
more details about what's happening and
why from Meerut at Oliver who's from the
center here what do we now know and
what's going to happen well last night
we have received a documentation
complete documentation from dr. Nicolini
the pediatrician oncologist from
Southampton which we are very happy for
of course so just to clear up you've got
all ash as medical details now and on
the basis of that you think you can
treat him here yes eight o'clock this
morning the concilium of our proton
therapy specialists and doctors make a
final statement that yes smaller jie
can be treated here okay so what happens
now well the information from dr.
Nicolini asset says that he is planning
two cycles of chemotherapy which will
take probably a couple of weeks and then
he is ready to refer him to Proton
Therapy Center check in Prague so
assuming everybody agrees he will have
two cycles of chemotherapy in the UK in
Southampton presumably and sometime
after that he will come here yes what
happens when he gets here well first
thing is that still the parents don't
forget about that them they have to
agree I mean we got an information
request asking us if we can treat him
and we said magnetical documentation is
needed which we have right now make the
concilium make the statement that yes we
can treat him but the parents they have
to say yes we want to take him to Prague
after the chemotherapy but you have
heard from the family in the last couple
of days I understand we just yes first
the request then
a couple of days ago the brother of
Naveed asked us if we can contact the
Spanish doctors which we did and we got
to respond from dr. Nicolini as I told
you and now we informed the parents that
it's possible that he get the treatment
here and we are waiting for them they
have to decide ok let's assume that they
do decide to come here given that that's
what they wanted to do in the first
place
when Asha arrives whenever that is what
will happen well we need some time in
his case four to five days to make and
prepare the irradiation plans and all
the fixation because he will need to be
stable during the treatment and after
those five four to five days the
treatment will begin and it will be 30
fractions so 30 days of irradiation
excluding Saturday and Sunday ok so he's
going to be here for a month five or six
weeks in total correct ok thank you very
much indeed so there you have it the
very latest clearly he's not here yet
but in every possibility and probability
Asha will be coming here and once he's
here he could be here for five or six
weeks